San Francisco is trying out another
Rebrand they just hired a new top
tourism official to convince folks that
the city is a safe and not a
crime-ridden hellhole he's also blaming
the media coverage of San Fran for the
perception that this city is in bad
shape and it looks like Nancy Pelosi
also wants to downplay her City's crime
crisis the top Democrats saying this
when announcing her re-election run how
do you turn San Francisco around
well let me just say that these attacks
are not unusual from the right but
nonetheless the fact is we do have an
isolated situation in these downtown San
Francisco and the tenderloin district
and the rest if there is crime and there
is violence and there are drugs there
will be arrest and that's the way it is
wow Nancy Pelosi Dana is talking arrest
in her new rebranding she's now an
anti-crime Crusader well also she just
announced remember yesterday or Friday
that she's going to run for office again
yep because she wants to fight for San
Francisco values which might sound like
satire to those of you watching the fact
is that the NAACP last month they asked
for more police resources you had the
mayor basically saying we're at a loss
remember when the she was heckled and
things were thrown at her drugs were
thrown at her when she tried to do the
press conference outside
I appreciate that you can hire a new
tourism official but you could also take
that money and put it into the police
department who absolutely needs it okay
you know what Greg what hit me in this
is is this statement that you know crime
is really kind of an isolated situation
and I thought isolated to whom the poor
the disenfranchised if that isolation is
okay no maybe her husband
yeah
right right yeah he was a victim I want
to help her uh I would I think that San
Francisco I mean I'm a Bay Area guy uh
it needs a PR makeover and as liberals
know it has to start with manipulating
the language right that's how you get
from genital mutilation to gender
affirmation so how do you help San
Francisco
get through all of this negative
publicity change the the words human
excrement is on the street those are
actually free-range brownies
discarded syringes that you hop over
pain Pals isn't that cute huh you know
Mass theft Community redistribution
homeless intents that's our kind of
creative off-the-grid living
state-of-the-art energy in water
independence with the very best in
foraging and sidewalk composting come by
stay for a while we promise we won't
stab you in the eye
you know Jesse what's interesting is
even the federal employees in San
Francisco are allowed to stay home
because it's so dangerous is she just
worried about certain people and not San
Francisco as a whole probably I mean
those sidewalk brownies are quite tasty
right I mean sometimes you get the
munchies
New Media has
no propaganda used to just be able to
tell people everything was fine now
everybody has this and they have these
feeds that show graphic content from San
Francisco it doesn't even have to you
have CNN reporters going out to do a
report they get carjacked NAACP guys
begging to refund the police didn't
their da just get booted you can't say
it's isolated when your husband got
hammered in the head by an illegal alien
that believed in fairies this city is
long gone they don't need a PR campaign
they just need willpower that's it and
you know what Jessica the the
interesting part is the crime went up
under her watch
her watch has been like four decades so
that's not really fair well but
answer go ahead sure I'm not going to
defend her anyway so we could just leave
that one
um the tenderloin has always been bad
I've spent tons of time in San Francisco
over the course of my whole life and
that has been consistent that my parents
have said no this isn't really a
neighborhood that we go to obviously the
problem is larger and when we talk about
Nordstrom and Whole Foods and gums and
people aren't going to Union Square uh
to shop the fact that hotel chains are
leaving
in droves and just saying it's not worth
it to us to be able to be open there
you know that it can't be fixed until
those things are addressed precisely and
yes you want a good PR person it's
always a value but you have to get the
businesses back and you have to get the
hotels back because you cannot have a
thriving City that wants tourists
without places for them to stay and
places for them to shop oh but that she
had a magic wand hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else